like okay i want to win a championship  and walk in uh  i'm gonna do whatever it takes in order  for for me to win it  and uh we did it we did it man this guy  right here pj  hey peach open the door please pj  pj hey sorry guys  hey bring your shoe this guy this guy  today he wanted 250 000 pair of shoe  he had real diamonds i promise  how much how much did it cost like yeah  basically basically a house in your feet  can i get them hey let me get them now  let me get them too can i you don't wear  your size  what's up  hey guys thank you guys this was a  a amazing journey the outcome was great  but even that for me it wasn't great  thank you guys for doing your job